[Music]
the first clip with their new camera you
know Barton vo and Joe all got it -
really camera is so cute it's literally
this big that's what you guys look like
that's the camera we're going to meet up
with chillin at the lounge in Boston we
have a 7 hour layover here and then we
head over to Iceland I don't know why I
booked this well I dunno why because
we're trying to meet up with Mama and
Papa Chan since they're coming from
Dallas but experiencing the actual plans
that I planned out like the whole
logistics of it all like living through
it I'm like mad at past TIFF cuz I'm
like why would you book such an early
flight have such a long layover we could
have just met them in Iceland but that's
okay we get to at least see them here
first okay so it's gonna go get them at
the front desk they're coming look at
you putting stuff away so fast oh that's
why I thought you were excited that I'm
on going a year here see ya okay bye
they're here it's a camera well yeah
it's the tiniest little camera how are
you
yeah it looks over Wow
so you like a James Bond yeah yeah look
I know I'm good I'm good I'm good I
gotta take a photo of it and I'm good at
I hold I'm slow okay keep logging -
that's my goodness camera is smaller
than your phone
I know his phone is like the whole hand
and then this camera like this is more
really hope is good quality it's great
quality not sponsored this thing is just
so cute
that is pleasing news I love how there's
ice on the floor I know this is really
dumb but I'm really impressed by the
bathrooms that they have at the airport
here it's like everyone has their own
little room but their toilet and then
the sink but then this think is so cool
so you put your hand right under here
and it's for the water but then on the
side
okay I'm easily entertained I know but I
like it so far all right so while we
wait for the bus we're gonna go check
out Isaac's first in-person snowfall
actually mine too because I just I saw
it in New York once but it was nothing
like this oh look at this it's snowing
like crazy you thought snow would be
loud that's cute what made you think it
was loud
[Applause]
oh that's like the heat trying to stay
in never seen you like this this is cool
huh baby go back inside I know your
gloves are in the luggage but it was too
hard to get so we're gonna get it once
we get to the hotel let's go inside now
pretty cool I know when you walk the
other way it starts hitting you all
right we made it to the first home this
is what it looks like
right there up your bedroom then there's
a kitchen a bathroom a washroom a dining
room pcs a KP a living room a mama Isaac
this is our bedroom I already started
like unpacking stuck since I use space
saver bags to vet like it's like a
vacuum seal to save space I ended up
just taking things out so I could
prepare for tomorrow so I'm planning
ahead and then there's the view of our
place it's snowing pretty hard so these
boys want to go outside and have a
snowball fight go down going down all
right have fun all right now we're gonna
have a snowball fight out in the snow
let's see how snowy it is look at that
snowing pretty hard blew the stairs when
we came it wasn't that bad Oh slippery
and hang on to the radios Oh
oh the neck no neck ready for conference
[Music]
me dude get closer
[Music]
oh man you suck you got him right in the
head
dude you're gonna be soaking wet so cute
it's a first snowball fight there we go
get on my dick
[Music]
Oh your cheeks are so red come here baby
oh no your glasses look at your cheeks
oh wow
think look at you compared to them they
look like BAM you have gotten hit Oh
what excuse me I know you had a great
first snowball fight
twenty cheek is numb
[Music]
right we're having our first meal at a
restaurant we're here at this place
called Network we ordered some whale
sashimi that's gonna be interesting
I'm looking forward to it because I like
to try weird things at least one right
now we're eating some bread and then
some Icelandic yogurt stuff what did
they call it again here scared that what
is that
bring it on
like steak
Frankie no all right so now my treat try
some wheel
[Music]
you like it like you
very source of all all the advocates
yeah there's a teeth there right that's
the game
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
really you didn't just whale
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
morning guys today is our first full day
of our tour we're doing a five-day tour
and then we have two extra days after
the tour to just roam around by
ourselves this is our first stop here
we're stopping at this place to get some
snacks and the boys are already inside
it's cold
what's that it's pretty soupy so oh okay
that's our baby
he's so cute I guess I can I want to try
some ISIL antics next I wonder what we
should get I got Icelandic hot dogs over
there are you gonna get one maybe okay
yeah but look they had a lot of the
American stuff that we're used to all
this stuff and then this I'm assuming is
a semantic popcorn you wanna try some
Icelandic popcorn yes all right Shack
you need oh yeah your bracelet you're
cute look at the puffins I want to see
some puffins in real life see you know
what even though I've been talking about
wanting to try a slant ik snacks and
stuff I'm really craving this so I'm
just gonna get this for the road don't
mind me
[Applause]
yeah sure
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
you guys have a chance comes in what a
cylinder yeah shake it up you know this
is amazing feel like I am in Winterfell
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
why that on camera
[Laughter]
[Music]
[Music]
Hey look how beautiful this is
I feel like I'm in a wallpaper this is
crazy look at the melting I dare you to
to get it one of those drops in your
mouth no destroying it how is it good
real water it is real water it's fresh
water I want to try it too
[Music]
oh yeah just good dude you're such a boy
this whole time he's just been trying to
like find snowballs and like climb she's
like stop taking photos guys I don't
know explore it can I throw it oh my god
where'd you think about all your
adventure adventure news from from your
mama nice okay let's go
[Music]
Ashton's really fine for a budget
submitted what about 50 minutes before
he goes to go back there
[Music]
they were just walking on Oreo cookies
and creams land right here
Wow beautiful Wow crazy what is this
what is this I think these are fish eggs
they just washed up bring it closer so I
could go back into the ocean yeah that's
it go back take him back take it back
take it back
and this is incredible that's like the
movie interstellar huh
looks like the movie scene it's like the
interstellar and they go those are
mountains their ways
[Music]
it is fun huh I like going in the deep
touches of snow and check out the
lighthouse
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
oh okay
[Music]
I like how I never get the hold for you
oh this is a free horse hi horsey hi oh
my gosh how cute you're so friendly hi
dude so fluffy oh my gosh I'm nursing a
horse that's fluffy he's awesome at me
excited I didn't think that they were
fluffy like that no earlier because
we've been driving a lot today and we
keep testing my horses and every time we
pass by them I keep thinking a little
horses back home right that have like
really short hair and I keep thinking
down horses are probably so cold but I'm
too close to my kitties for some reason
it was my cat alright we're at our first
hotel for the tour so technically or
second hotel and awesome it was unlocked
go for it baby I was about to have Isaac
open it with the key Oh cute look at
that you have your little bed you Wow
look at this I love this all right so
we're settling into our first hotel on
the couch just stop coming in the first
hotel and we're gonna go have dinner we
just came to leave all our luggages
there's a cute little desk over there
it's not the bathroom there I thought it
was a closet let me check out the
bathroom
okay okay oh yeah you guys I don't find
something gross but yeah what is that
no oh my god that's it those are
someone's panties it looks like a little
girl's panties yeah that's gross we're
not opening that drawer again what's in
that one you already checked oh it is
broken oh there's a key in there you can
see the key oh okay there now you can
mess with the old school kind of oh my
gosh I don't know their luck it so no
one sees it ever again this thing is
gonna fall why'd you open it again
oh nice hey what's up guys hope you guys
liked our first Iceland vlog sorry it
takes me a while to get through the
footage we record a lot when we go on
vacations and it takes a couple of days
to you know sort through all the footage
and to put together a cohesive video and
if any of you guys go on vacations and
also have lots of footage you don't know
what to do with it go check out the
description below you'll see a link for
life with the camera calm which is the
video course TIFF and I have put out
showing you guys how we put together our
videos how we shoot how we edit and how
we ultimately craft our videos it's a
one-time payment for a lifetime
and plus we're working on new material
to add to our video course Oh check it
out wife with the camera calm and see
you guys on the next Iceland vlog
[Music]
[Music]